hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
da wollte ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut mir auch heute machen wir was cool
ist was ich na ja ich will nicht sagen
geklaut habe ich sag mal so ich habe
mich da ein bisschen inspirieren lassen
wir können uns gerne kurz hinsetzen und
zwar ich mir gestern glaube ich ein
video angeschaut von alexei becks idee
hat der von media markt und saturn so
china produkte getestet und ich fand das
ziemlich interessant der hat unter
anderem auf seinem gameboy vorgestellt
und das war also dieses game modell war
der allererste gameboy den ich selber
früher mal so mit 3 1
[Musik]
also wirklich 3 und hatte das manchmal
diesen doofen manchmal mit diesen
gameboy spielen da waren wir ganz ganz
am anfang von games würde ich mal sagen
auf jeden fall ist es leider so dass
zurzeit sehr sehr viele produkte die ich
bayerisch oder anderen shops bestellt
habe die ich mir selber irgendwo
zusammen gekauft haben oder ihr habt ihr
vielleicht auch dieses 400 euro wie
shopping video gesehen das dauert alles
extrem lange bis die sachen ankommen da
sind totale lieferschwierigkeiten linke
oder wäre es dann ganz ganz viele lager
zu dann braucht es nur hier was bedeutet
die ganzen chinesen haben irgendwie ein
monat frei und schicken gar nichts los
also da fehlen noch so viele sachen und
mir waren einfach die hände gebunden ich
konnte kein video machen und deswegen
habe ich mir jetzt gedacht dann machst
du doch wenigstens jetzt mal so was wo
du selber im laden ist ich bin so media
markt gegangen und habe mal geschaut
welche sachen die dort ausstellen könnte
man auch aus china bestellen und habe
ein paar sachen gefunden die wir jetzt
hier haben
aber wie gesagt das ganze habe ich
gesehen weil alex sexy video ist in der
beschreibung verlinkt er hat auch schon
mal so ein paar sachen da vorgestellt
aber wir haben heute hier andere sachen
zum einen haben wir dieses ding habe ich
bei media markt gekauft und ich habe
alles für media markt gekauft dann haben
wir irgend so ein joystick den kann ich
sogar mit meinem für 24 99
dann habe ich hier den wollte mir auf
jeden fall kaufen für 39 99 diesen alten
oder naja gut die welt immer noch
produziert neun games
also in alten neuen game aber es wäre
kein original a game.de das ist der
retro bild kennt sie nicht
das ist total in unter sind sogar 260
spiele drauf meinte wir sind direkt
darauf ja ne weiter ich weiß schon dass
ich alles sehr oft in meinem bett hängen
werden und das zocken werde und dann
habe ich hier noch irgendwie eine lampe
gekauft die habe ich direkt also warte
mal die hat um 24 9 einzige kostet die
habe ich direkt im internet für zehn
euro gefunden wo wir immer bestellen
oder würde ich mal sagen was man damit
anfangen oder von der man sollte zum
beispiel haben wir hier bei wisch diese
wanderungen led lampe für 12 euro hier
kostet 25 euro
ich habe mir die eigentlich in erster
linie nur bestellt um den hintergrund zu
stellen auf einem neuen kanal so ruhig
auch mal sachen wie reagiere ich sehr
gerne in der bibel schon abonniert den
und deswegen packen wir jetzt mal aus
das gefällt uns schon mal ganz gut ist
das kabel nicht zu kurz ist man merkt
schon auf jeden fall diese qualität ist
scheiße
hier ist immer auch eine beschreibung
dabei könnte auf jeden fall gut von muss
sein akku leer
nein nach fünf euro kann man nicht
meckern oder community wieder aufs feld
von meinem mac box set kohlhepp na ja
aber ich stelle jetzt da ins regal
dann sieht man im hintergrund eine
leuchtende frau es kann ja eben eine
frau sein oder die doch was macht dein
gesicht drauf war das werk wenn zu den
dingen von mir geben würde gibt es
leider nicht
naja leute das ist produkt nummer eins
was ich nicht installiert das kurz guck
mal sieht ganz gut aus oder mir so schön
aber ich wieder ein bisschen mehr
gefüllt
damit bin ich zufrieden auch wenn ich es
natürlich im internet machen wir weiter
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist das
habe ich einfach mitgenommen ich habe es
auch im internet gefunden
wir haben hier game controller said
händel mag keine ahnung was das heißt
hat glaube ich also mal sieben euro
gekostet mack ist tastet
das habe ich von auch für media markt
ist ja langweilig obwohl ist eigentlich
geil so schwer kann mich dann immer noch
sehr wenige abend ich dachte wenn es
irgend was für ein komfort lassen drin
wir haben hier eine motorrad außer für
meinen kaffee macht besteht notheis
marktgasse game mag ich dachte das heißt
es oder nicht ich mir jetzt muss ich los
und es tut es aber alter mag ich kenne
nur waka waka also da trinkt gleich
erstmal einen kaffee heraus nur wieso
gibt es so was bei media markt ist hier
die frage
für den kleinen ort zwischen für den
kleinen ändert übrigen zwischendurch mag
okay dann würde ich sagen mach mal
weiter auf den nicht richtig gespannt
das wird mein videoschnitt
revolutionieren und zwar kann ich damit
an meinem imac arbeiten in dem ich
diesen touristik machen ihre der 24 99
gibt es eigentlich noch eben menschen
der linux benutzt außer alte menschen
weiß ich gar nicht
das soll eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht war solltest du diesen weg muss
ich sogar sagen hat mich hier wie schon
gesagt 24 990 gekostet im internet finde
ich denn nicht günstiger deswegen
charmanten kleinen daumen nach oben von
mir dafür sollte vor der
verständlichkeit
was mich hier erwartet
da ist man uns schreiben bei steigen
[Musik]
meinte ich kann meinem ausgelegt ja
nicht blöd wenn ich hier draufdrücken
explodiert ein computer ganz wichtig für
alle die mir geschrieben haben
allerdings bestellte nicht bayerisch
corona virus kann sich nicht darüber
verbreiten wenn jetzt jemand der korona
hat dieses ding eingepackt hat sondern
nur wenig direkten kontakt zu dem hat
das heißt die korona viren können wir
darauf nicht überleben wollen wir zu ihm
und gehe hier ist in der tat keine
beschreibung weil wieso wird das nicht
da stand auch drauf kompatibel mit mac
okay leute jetzt habe ich dir hier einen
windows laptop angeschlossen
ich glaube das war ein schock auf man
braucht glaube ich ich weiß nicht
vielleicht geht es mit dem gameboy aber
man braucht glaube ich so eine konsole
dafür dürfte das hält was hatten dass
damit mac zu tun leute wenn ihr das
wissen schreibt gern meine kommentare
und ein bisschen überfragt irgendwie ist
das jetzt ein bisschen lärm muss ich
sagen wollte aber sonst gekauft oder wir
können jetzt gleich hier an anschließen
oder ich finde noch aus wie es geht
keine ahnung
jetzt wird erst mal eine runde gameboy
gesorgt
hast du mal die kirche
weltmeisterschaften gesehen gibt es
dabei natürlich wer hätte das gedacht
mal wieder batterien oder sind hier
welche bei
[Musik]
wir sind halt echt mega viele spiele
drauf megaman
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bin gestorben die frau
stürmt weiter aus ja leute das ist auf
jeden fall ein geiles ding mit diesem
fakt wie soll ich da kann ich jetzt
nichts anfangen
kontinuität ist sehr vielen ja gut
nintendo 64 mal wahrscheinlich zu fühlen
ich hatte früher sogar mal ein mit tempo
der war so blau der sid aus recht wenn
ich das noch geld das wir irgendwie
hinkriegen sollte tages nach ansonsten
waren das jetzt schon die ganzen sachen
also diesen gameboy feiere ich brutal
von media markt die leute danke fürs
zuschauen ich hoffe ja ein bisschen spaß
und ich freue mich mega auf die ganzen
sachen nicht bestellt habe dass sie
endlich mal ankommen ich hoffe das
passiert schnell und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder um 19 uhr gibt's neues
video
haut rein